help Ukraine to Shield its cities from
Russian bombs and Iranian drones
and that's why the United Kingdom will
be the first country to provide Ukraine
with longer range weapons and it's why
we're working with our allies to give
Ukraine the most advanced air defense
systems and build the Air Force they
need to defend their Nation
but to win the peace we also need to
rebuild the international order on which
our collective security depends
first that means upholding international
law
the whole world must hold Russia to
account
we must see Justice
through the ICC for their sickening war
crimes committed
whether in butcher Urban Mario poll or
Beyond
and Russia must also be held to account
for the terrible destruction it has
inflicted